vamos a calcular el rotacional en dos
dimensiones de un campo vectorial y el
que tengo en mente es el siguiente vamos
a poner como primera componente a que
cubica menos 9 y como segunda componente
o componente q verdad va a ser lo mismo
pero con x x cúbica menos 9 x muy bien
este es nuestro campo vectorial y en el
vídeo anterior nosotros descubrir
descubrimos cómo calcular el rotacional
en dos dimensiones por supuesto para
nuestro campo vectorial de verdad
evaluado en el punto x
y esto es tiene tiene una fórmula muy
sencilla y es la derivada parcial de la
de la segunda componente que es q con
respecto de x menos la derivada parcial
de p con respecto de g
muy bien esa es la fórmula que nosotros
descubrimos para calcular el rotacional
y sólo para para que quede más o menos
claro por si no recuerdas mucho de cómo
hicimos esto si nosotros nos fijamos en
este punto y tenemos una situación más
- así en donde digamos la circulación de
este fluido hace una rotación más o
menos de este estilo cuando nos movemos
en la dirección horizontal verdad
estamos moviéndonos de izquierda a
derecha la componente curva de negativo
0 a positivo entonces esto digamos la
función que crece al incrementar x lo
cual nos dice que esta derivada parcial
es positiva en cambio cuando vamos de
abajo hacia arriba es decir aumentamos
en nuestra variable y vamos de positivo
0 negativo en la componente de verdad
entonces esta derivada parcial dado que
disminuye pues será negativo pero con
este signo menos se vuelve positivo y
por eso es que este ejemplo típico tiene
rotacional positivo verdad pero bueno
entonces fijémonos ahora en este caso
particular fijémonos en la componente q
verdad y vamos a calcular la derivada
con respecto de x entonces al derivar
respecto de x tendremos
x cuadrada menos nueve verdad
simplemente derivamos esto y ahora
restamos lo que sea digamos la derivada
de p con respecto de ya que
esencialmente es lo mismo pero con de
verdad 3 y cuadrada menos
entonces aquí tenemos ya el valor del
rotacional para este campo vectorial
verdad y ahora vamos a tratar de
interpretar lo que esto significa de
hecho este campo vectorial es el mismo
que te mostré en la animación cuando
empezamos a desarrollar la intuición
detrás del rotacional teníamos partes
específicas donde el rotacional es
positivo y donde el rotacional es
negativo de hecho podemos ver en este
caso porque tenemos valores positivos o
negativos por eso escogimos en realidad
este ejemplo verdad si vemos digamos
cuando el rotacional es positivo esto se
da cuando x es igual a 3 y ya es igual a
cero así que volvamos aquí y pongamos
justamente el caso en el que x es igual
a 3 y qué
es igual a 0 muy bien entonces en este
caso qué es lo que ocurre si sustituimos
estos valores tendremos 3 por 3 al
cuadrado menos 9 y restamos 3 por 0 3
por 0 - 9 verdad entonces aquí
tendríamos 3 por 9
esto sería 27 y si restamos 9 nos da 18
y luego restamos 3 por 0 0 menos 9 es
menos 9 verdad con este menos 2 nos da
más verdad más 9 y esto nos da 27 lo
cual es un valor positivo verdad
entonces si regresamos a la animación
por eso es que vemos que en este punto
la rotación se da en el sentido
contrario a las manecillas del reloj muy
bien entonces si ahora nosotros
regresamos otra vez aquí y cambiamos el
punto digamos ya no ya no será x igual a
3 ni igual a cero ahora lo cambiamos por
equis igual a cero
x igual a 0 y igual a 3 vamos a borrar
todo esto borremos todo esto para que no
nos vaya a distraer entonces si
regresamos a la animación tenemos que
aquí la rotación se da en el sentido de
las manecillas del reloj verdad entonces
esperaríamos que el rotacional fuera
negativo así que vamos a calcularlo aquí
tendríamos 3 x 0 al cuadrado verdad
menos 9 y luego restamos 3 porque
cuadrada que sería 3 por 3 al cuadrado
menos 9 entonces tres por cero al
cuadrado es cero verdad esto nos va a
dar menos 9 menos 3 por 3 al cuadrado es
27 si le restamos 9 es 18 verdad
entonces tendríamos menos 9 menos 18 y
esto es menos 27 verdad entonces
justamente tenemos un valor negativo
regresando a la animación debido a que
el valor del rotacional es negativo
corresponde a que hay una circulación
digamos en el sentido de las
manecillas del reloj y si ponemos
digamos en esta fórmula x igual a cero
igual a cero pues entonces tendríamos
menos nueve menos menos nueve que nos da
justamente cero entonces en la animación
vemos porque no hay rotación en general
en el en el origen verdad y en realidad
podríamos pensar en esta rotación para
cualquier punto en el en el plano verdad
solo hay que ponerlo en esta fórmula que
hemos obtenido aquí y así podríamos
saber digamos cuál sería la rotación
alrededor de ese punto verdad y así que
con esto puedes ver que en realidad es
una herramienta muy poderosa verdad
regresando a la animación si tenemos un
flujo digamos muy complicado y te
pidiera que me des un número que me dé
la dirección general y la fuerza de
rotación alrededor de cada punto bueno
eso sería mucha información así que
siempre es bueno tener una fórmula
compacta a la mano